okay welcome everyone to today's
infrastructure meeting 8th of November
and we're going to start live streaming
apologies
we have councilor Scout and councilor
sopa can I please have someone move that
move Grant second to Darren put that
motion all those in favor all right
hence that's carried I'm going to
dispense with the housekeeping notes
since we were all councilors staff and
long-serving media we all know the rules
for the evacuation oh yeah which one
um right that I'm gonna jump straight
into receiving three major late items
they are proposed right of way names
182 and 186 Grant Road uh proposed
right-of-way name for 299 at ramica Road
and also temporary road closure for the
South City Street party can I have
someone moved there we receive those
late homes thanks Alex moved and
seconded Barry
I'll put the emotional as in favor
thank you uh there is no public forum uh
remind everyone of uh members interests
and which reminds myself that I have a
conflict in the opening item
um item four for the temporary road
closure
uh Alice being on the committee for the
Santa parade my wife Tom is going to
cheer this item
thanks Tom thank you
um so the minutes will record uh about
councilor pottinger declared an interest
and stepped down from the chair and [ __ ]
said then from the committee for the
purposes of this discussion
um we have the paper temporary road
closures invercargill Santa parade on
page four
I think this is pretty self-evident but
um
does anybody have any questions for
officers
next year Aaron uh is there anything
different this year to what happened in
what was proposed last
not to my understanding but Mr Pearson
will be able to clarify
other questions
so Mr Pearson was just
sorry Russell can we just get you to
come to the speaker
it's not my paper but I understand that
the um the parade setup is on Gala
Street rather than on Calvin Street for
this year so I think normally the parade
when they stick the um the elements they
normally are down Calvin street but I
think it's Gala street so it's a slight
difference but the route's the same so
the disruption will be relatively minor
and will publicly advertise the buses
bus route so it's um
thanks for your chair the setup has
quite often been on garter Street in the
past other Gala were governed so if
there's nothing different I'm happy to
remove the three recommendations okay I
have one other question sorry councilor
Kate you have a question no I'm just
going to see him okay I I have a
question
um
Nathan I notice in the person summary
the paragraph that starts the site to
allows Council to close the road after
consultation with the New Zealand Police
and Waka kotahi
um can I assume that that consultation
has already taken place
I believe so
okay
I'll take that as yes
okay so we have three recommendations
um they're obviously joined so we'll
take them at the same time
will somebody move those recommendations
seconded
um is it anybody who wishes to speak
against this
okay that being the case I'll put the
motion loose in favor say aye aye
against carried
thank you and haven't had my one minute
30 seconds of Fame I'll hand back to the
wheelchair
thank you
all right that takes us now to item five
which is
[Music]
um
Solid Waste update and we have Peter
Nolan Peter would you like to please
take a seat and a microphone
and the floor is yours
so
um as promised continuing uh update on
the solid waste
we can see that this month that
um
waste has started to increase and
continues to increase
we'd forecasted last year there'd be a
five to six percent increase in waste
we're currently running around about
three percent
we continue to progress with
um the initiatives we put in place which
is to assess the wmmp and the waste
waste activity plan
and we're putting our education strategy
together which includes engaging
external specialist waste organizations
such as paracore
and we've been speaking with environment
Southlands for environment School
virus schools
um we've been speaking with um waste
free Annie or I believe the children
absolutely love and have some great
outcomes from that all all these will be
intended to be measured to show the
investment in these education providers
um
in terms of recycling recycling seems to
have gone down gone down a bit
um but we really don't know what that
what that is at the moment whether it's
the time of year
or or the reasons behind that because
we've come into a brand new world I
suppose
um X covet no more masks people be being
more abundant and coming out into the
environment so further analysis will be
required through the year to have a look
at have a look through through this
we've also gone to market for uh to fill
the waste positions of which we've had
an excellent response I think we've got
some very strong candidates which we're
hoping to appoint in the next few weeks
which will be able to really focus in on
this and drive it forward for us
okay so that that covers both item five
and 5.1 about the update okay so uh
we're gonna open the floor for questions
of Peter from anyone regarding
uh what the report is about
can we have any questions
uh
Evelyn
thank you Mr chair
um just I'm trying to get my head around
what if anything we can do
to make
changes because
when a lot of people can't burn things
anymore you know because they don't have
fireplaces so therefore that's more
paper goes to
um
how I mean we do we discourage people
from buying newspapers and sorry at the
back but the South and express not only
be online or things like that I I'm
struggling to get my head around how we
can make meaningful changes to some of
this
when it's not actually really within
Council or Council offices power to make
that change
we can do all the education we like but
there's some realities that we've got to
come to grips with and if we can't
be
disposing of the rubbish in our own
backyard or in our own fireplace or
whatever then we put it in our bins what
are the Alternatives that we should be
showing to the community to make a
difference
I'm happy to take that one if you'd like
Pete
um so I guess what you're talking about
Evelyn is a more strategic I guess
approach moving forward and that's
something that we'd flagged that we
wanted to kick off at about this time
this year post post the election process
so that we could take everybody I guess
through that process of what's Happening
nationally in the waste space because
you're absolutely right our role as
council is only part of that broader
picture there are some things that we
can do locally in terms of our
contamination rates are still high in
terms of what's going into the recycling
bins so that means that not everything
that we would like to recycle that
people are actually putting out and
their bins can be recycled because once
those contamination rates are too high
some recycling does have to go to the
landfill so the education side of it can
really help us clean up our act so that
we're producing good quality research
cycling that has better chance of you
know being ultimately diverted from
landfill we also need to look at what
funding is available federally and
perhaps what we can do at a regional
level in terms of dealing with more
locally but that's a process that we're
going to run over the next six to 12
months to look at what can we do in the
waste space strategically moving forward
over the next five ten years
so as a follow-up to that
does that mean perhaps that we need to
look at whether we target
once a month we will collect your paper
if you've wrapped you know if you've put
it separately tied a string around it
um put it there or your cardboard or
things like so that it's not going into
your yellow burn and necessarily having
other things put on top of it is that
part of the answer ideally not because
the moment we start separating things
out of bins we have to have people on
the side of the road collecting them and
that's a problem for the waste industry
because people outside of trucks too
many people are still being injured and
killed going under Vehicles so ideally
we'd be looking at solutions that still
keep people in trucks but it may mean
that we are looking to divert into more
bins things like that and there may be
some push from central government as
well that mandate diverting into more
bins as well
I guess a couple of issues
um I know it's on page 15 of uh
of the report here that it talks about
Bond Contracting uh checking the bins
we've had this before and so this is not
the first time
um and I guess leading up on what
evidence it is is the contamination is
predominantly Glass isn't it
so one of the issues we have as a
council is that we only have two bins
most other councils I think only Us in
Christchurch are the odd ones here have
three bins so they take glass out of the
system and while you're leaving in the
recycling bin which most people do
because I think glass can be recycled
um it breaks up it contaminates
everything else and then some of the
interim landfill which costs everybody
so I mean we've been around this for I
don't know three four years now I guess
we need to make some tough decisions
somewhere online I'm picking
um but uh whether we have a third bin or
not what we do with the glass I guess in
the interim is it your advice at the
glass should go into the non-recyclable
bin
thanks for the question not not at this
stage so we've been working closely with
the contractor we know that glass in the
mixed recycle bin causes a problem at
the processing facility
um but it's not to such an extent that
at this stage they're saying to us you
have to get it out right now
um they are giving us some time to
explore whether or not we would be
getting it out via a separate glass Spin
and what other methods we have of
dealing with it we have had some
discussions with Christchurch as well as
to whether there's any market for our
glass out there in terms of back into
bottles but at this stage that's
unlikely
um so we aren't at this stage looking at
that whole of Life recycling we are just
simply looking at that diversion
um into roading Aggregates things like
that
um definitely something though one one
of those chunky issues we're going to
need to bring back to council to work
through through over the next six to 12
months
a couple of other issues on the same
page I see the waste resourcing
structure has a manager coordinator and
a commercial contracts manager is that
is that purely for ICC
uh no so that covers both IC that covers
waste net obligations as well as ICC
okay
finally um
down the bottom it says in a racist
before
is that recycled South might be moving
to makariwa and while that might be
their option two that commercially if
we've got a contract with them we've got
some control as well and so at the
moment uh recycle South provide a
drop in slots on the side of the
building where you can recycle stuff so
no secret there's there's no city
council recycling into otatara for
argument's sake which is 10 of our
population base
um and I'm not sure anybody you know all
the people know Tara would want that but
the moment we take stuff into town so
I'm picking that people living otara
will not go to my career or to take
their glass and tins and other things so
will there be some facility in town
where that can still be dropped off you
know so at this stage we haven't had
confirmation from the contractors to
what elements of their operation may
move to macarawa they may continue to
keep the processing where it is
um or that but we have directed them
that if there was an eventuality where
they did move that processing that it
would need to come back to council to
discuss the impacts of that and that we
expected that there would still be a
requirement to have that public drop-off
facility in the city
and just a final question which is back
on the bottom Contracting a proposal to
check the bins
so what what are we potentially asking
them to check because you said to me
before that there's no intention at this
stage to take glass out of the recycling
bin which is where it does the damage at
the moment because it breaks once it
gets in the trucks
um
so when if we're not giving them a
message to put it in the other bin then
what will be rechecking
so at the moment we we are exploring
some proposals around checking what we
do need to work through is the balance
between I guess carrot and stick making
sure that we've got the right education
balance as well as the right regulatory
balance but in terms of what we're
actually checking we wind up in the
recycle bin with a range of items that
aren't recyclable at all down to rubbish
nappies surprisingly sometimes dead
animals in the recycling bin those are
the things that we we want to clean up
we want to make sure that only those
things that we are advising are
recyclable are going into that bin so
it's not a focus on glass at this stage
not at this stage it's all good very
yeah no my question's been out that I
was going to bring up a bit the cost
contamination yeah to win the grass
glass and the cardboard
that sounds like you're on the case
already okay uh three years the chair
part of my question's also been answered
um back to knobby but what I wanted to
come back to was a strategic Direction
with the recycling and I wondered if
there had been a view by Council
um strategically to look at glass
recycling hubs throughout our city maybe
iot premises to um have a specific
targeted ear for that glass to go to
albeit you could add tin as well we used
to do that in the 80s and 90s
um so they'd always helped and it could
help with that cross-contamination yeah
absolutely it's um something that I'm
aware of in other areas where they
haven't had a separate glass collection
that they have had those areas where you
can drop off at supermarkets stadiums
things like that the difficulty we have
down here at the bottom of the south
island is you have to have somewhere to
then send the glass to be recycled back
into bottles and at the moment we don't
have that market
um Queenstown I think we're one of the
last ones who managed to get into
Christchurch and actually have their
glass whole of Life recycled they are
even struggling to keep it going there
because what they've found now is
they've been able to clean up their
contamination but the transport process
is breaking the glass up and I who do
the processing out of Christchurch have
so much glass coming to them they're
becoming quite picky about they want the
pieces to be bigger and things like that
so that's the the difficulty for us as
we simply don't have that South Island
recycling plant to send it to okay thank
you
you know like just a bit of information
regarding co-mingling
uh the whole bin system started in 2010
and it was two years 2012 into it where
wastenet realized that it was a mistake
to have come England okay
um there's a there's a sort of Catch-22
situation where the damage occurs when
the the truck picks it up and compacts
it so but
the compactor has set at a certain level
so that it doesn't damage too much glass
and of course you can't fit as much in
that truck as you possibly could which
in turn means you've got to do more
traps which cost more money so look
removing the glass is one thing we
definitely need to look at without a
doubt and we know we've had before
report on that McGregor concreting is is
using it for a routing aggregate a new
machine
Peter part of moving forward the removal
of glass is that going to come from
a report or how's how we're going to
look at that the feasibility of that and
the costs involved we were currently
actively have some content Consultants
actively looking at that and
um looking at sources of funding for it
from the um the materials reduction fund
and the other the other one that's on
the horizon that other councils are
looking at is the removal
of kitchen waste from the Redmond now
that changes the game because the ribbon
then doesn't have to be uh collected as
often so is that another one that's
being looked at as well sure we're
certainly looking at the frequency and
periods for picking up especially if we
end up moving to a full bin uh situation
and then a composting facility as well
sure definitely
um
just
I've got questions regarding the waste
minimization management plan and it's
around the
it's around the target of what we're
aiming for per capita and it states in
the plan at 650 kilograms per capita
with 40 percent of that being diverted
away from landfill now are we looking at
this increase is forecast for six
percent in reality it's been three are
we looking at
changing our Target because are we is
that achievable do you know what our
current per capita rate is
um I don't off the top of my head but I
can certainly you find it and bring it
to you just that that Target is is part
of our sort of legislative requirement
under the ACT is that when we set these
both divisions and targets and and goals
I'm just wondering if it's not
achievable then we have to
we have to have another look at it sure
and and certainly that's something that
um the the people coming into the waste
roles we'll be looking at
speak to the fact that going into the
next long-term plan
um I absolutely agree we have to look at
that Target and decide what is realistic
for our level of investment
um because that tendency for councils to
around the country talk about having
zero increase to landfill comes with a
significant investment
um is that actually something that's
realistic for
um invercargill city
um or should we be actually looking at
something that is achievable and will
drive the right behaviors from us
I I just know also Peter I noticing your
on page
um 15 where it says plan progress
it states that the wmmp
uh is an evolving
um
document with a new legislation coming
in now there's a bit of a catch there
because if we if this plan changes
aren't we then susceptible to
um going out to consult as it states for
section 83 of the ACT
sure but this legislation won't be
coming in for a period we've then got to
understand what what it means to us we
also then have to develop the plan
before we even consider going out of
consultation it's it's a real tough one
because we've got four years to go
before this
waste minimization plan expires or we
start looking at the new one and and uh
it's just not looking that good at the
moment but looking forward to your
reports on
um so if we're changing to a multiple
bin system and stuff like that we will
have to consult correct
yes yeah yeah
no that's fine so any more questions
from anyone we've got actually we've got
um two lots of recommendations uh the
first lot of recommendations is on page
six
um there's four there that we received
the solar waste their plate report note
the waste to landfill data and Trends
note the recycling data and Trends note
the planned approach
uh with regards to solarized activities
in 12 months plan can I please have
someone move that thank you Darren
seconded knobby I'm going to put that
motion all those in favor
and that takes us to the second lot of
recommendations
uh we received the report solar white
State sorry I think that's just the
report from the previous meeting ah just
for continuity oh right right right
thank you for that
hit me double reporting oh
that is done and dusted and that moves
us on to the activity report which
covers a myriad of
activities
within our infrastructure Department
um
says
Aaron new Poland and I see your name at
the top of this we've got everything
from speed limit changes
uh Steed Street
um
artwork and also a pump house and I
think people may want to comment on
thank you chair uh the pieces that I'd
just like to highlight and speak to uh
firstly with regard to the work that's
currently happening with council with
three Waters reform
um just advising that there is quite a
bit that's going on in the background
with requests for information coming
from the new entities into the
organization
um so I think we're we've ticked off a
couple but a couple of weeks ago we had
about six different requests for
information within the business
um that we're all coming in it is taking
up quite a bit of time
um both of myself and Michael day
um because we're they're covering across
information both on our assets but also
planning around how we're going to
integrate data and digital I.T systems
uh what has to happen across people and
capability what are staff's conditions
things like that so that's all
information that we're having to
proactively feed into at the moment so
just providing an update that that is
still happening in the background
the other piece that I just wanted to
draw attention to is the work on
steadstreet obviously there's been some
disruption for the community there with
the construction of the stock Bank
um we're getting close to the end of the
disruption for invercargill City in
terms of the artwork is on track to be
installed by the end of the year however
just wanting to note that anybody who's
headed out that way will be aware that
work has commenced from environments
Southland on the pump station out there
they will that will also continue to
have an impact on traffic
over the next 12 months potentially
we're just working with them to try to
keep abreast of the sequencing of their
works that will involve work at the pump
station site on the side of the road but
also will involve piping under the road
and we're expecting a diversion to be in
place for a period of time again when
that happens but we're just working
closely with environments Southland to
keep on top of when that will need to
happen the other pieces that we held off
resealing that road whilst the stock
Bank construction was happening we've
now pushed that about as far as we can
and we need to re-seal that road in this
upcoming season
um only expected to take a few days less
than a week but just making people aware
of that and the final piece of that will
be just noting as I'm sure the question
will be asked was will that mean that
after we seal that road is it likely
that the work's happening with the pump
station will have to cut into that new
seal
that is likely to be the case but the
advice that I might ask Russell Pearson
to speak further to it is that at the
moment we're already having the road
starting to break apart it is actually a
better outcome for the road to do a
structured cut into it
um after it's been resealed than it is
to wait to reach seal that road even
longer until that pump station work has
been completed so not ideal but a better
overall outcome Russell did you have
anything to add to that piece
okay and then I'd also ask can you just
come up to the table just to talk
through the drive my life very briefly
why it's been resealed and then dug up
um we can absolutely do that I think it
would be useful yeah just so that
they're aware of the fact that we've
proactively made that choice yeah
it's not enough I would I would
concur with that because it's really is
that it is it is quite a deliberate
decision for us to seal the road
um we will look to actually limit the
seal in the area where the pump station
is so it doesn't
unless it's more economic to do that so
we're just working that through with the
contractor but the explanation that we
haven't sealed it and then dug it up is
actually the message that we want to do
and it's quite deliberate because we
don't need to hold the seal for a for a
longer period of times
um thanks for the opportunity just to
briefly overview the drive my life drive
my life as one of the um one of our road
safety promotion educational programs
that we support
um with our shared service with um
SL southern district and Gore District
Council so that's um part of a program
where the community has come together to
actually encourage those people who
don't seem to be able to get through
their driver license sequencing and
actually support them to so they do have
a license so the first time they
interact with the police isn't being
stopped without it without a license and
that's been a hugely successful program
and it's helping those people greatly
and it's won a national award so we
think it's one of those Road Safety
opportunities that we want to recognize
because I think it actually does
something really great for the wider
community and helps those people
they become much better against drivers
because the opportunity to be mentored
mentored by
um The Wider community and we look to
continue to support that so happy to
answer any questions
I'd just like to say
um
pretty it's actually made a difference
for many people's lives
I just want to know
thank you uh Nobby yeah I'm just in
relation to the um
State Street area
um good to hear the cultural work is
going at the end of the year because
that's going to be quite stunning Aaron
you mentioned a possible version so just
a couple of issues on that
um
I
um earlier last week I sent an invite to
the chair in Byron southam and one of
his senior staff to come and talk to us
about this whole project
um
a bit of community unease I guess is a
nice way of putting it but we're
we do all the state three stuff and then
we we hack up the road and do it again
because of the pump station so I guess
there's a wanting to understand but
certainly my understanding from the
chair of environment Southerners it
would not create a diversion it might
create one-way traffic
as they work through that but not a
around Bay Road type situation again so
it'd be helpful to get some
clarification on that because I'm not
sure when he's going to arrive
and the other suggestion that Trish came
up with about notifying the community
certainly we want to get onto the
otatara Motorsport
which is a local noticeable and then
those that live in odotara can deal with
the flag that we get because we'll be
able to comment back because that's
actually quite a good way to say hey
this is a rationale but I'm while we're
doing what we're doing so
but it would be helpful to know that
there's not a diversion and I think
um illness Russ has got anything to add
we'll do our best to work with
environments Southland to keep on top of
that
um but primarily we will be pushing them
to provide that good communication so on
that note I'm sorry just with the issue
of the cultural uh works that we you
should be up at the end of the year
um will that require any sort of road
closure at all do you think
you can't actually use the bank at the
moment only in terms of um to the point
likely to be potentially some periods of
short one way that's okay but it'll be
in the in the middle of the section so
not those impacts on the roundabouts in
the airport that we were wanting to
avoid yeah that's good thank you so on
that note of
um the traffic management that
environment Southland will need in
certain cases Russell are we going to
get
um forewarned um we're going to get to
advance notice that with what Nobby was
talking about so we can they're going to
bring it to us
each of the stages of their work will
will require them to submit to us a
traffic management plan for Council
approval to consider what that traffic
impact is and how they will manage the
traffic
right so they don't just fire ahead and
do their stuff they're going to go
through us if yep and each of those have
for instance they have a daytime and a
nighttime plan so they actually have to
have a an attendant in an unattended
site so that's how we would normally and
would that come back to this committee
first
we'll just be staff operating in the
background normally that would be an
operational decision that we would
manage but if we had some significant
I guess issues or greater information we
needed to communicate we would certainly
be bringing it as an information item
and Russell corrected me if I'm wrong
but that wouldn't include specific dates
out of that that information
um the dates are often a little bit more
difficult but we would have a range of
dates often the traffic management is a
longer period but we would be trying to
focus it down to make sure we understood
fully what they were doing
okay any further questions on the
activities report
yes
come on
should we
um didn't
touch at all on the new speed limits
um I guess I had
from what I've heard
um people seem to have generally
accepted it I mean I've had nobody
picked my door down Alberta with one
exception and I know we don't want to
talk about individual roads but I won't
mention the one exception is from the
ready bridge to the beach
where I don't think anybody can quite
understand why that's I've been in 60
kilometers an hour
um is there a reason for that
that's a question for Russell obviously
the research
came up with that number I'm a part of
that uh it's a good question and part of
that is that section of the ready River
to the beach has had a number of crashes
um we also believe it's the safe and
appropriate speed part of that is the
the shape of the road
and it's a question of how do you make
sure it's consistently applied and we
believe the 60ks is probably more like
the environment we would actually like
people to be using it
and you are right we've had quite a
smooth transition to the news new speed
so it's been quite well received I guess
there's been a few people certainly who
have rang me who've had differing views
but um you know generally that's what
we're seeing is a reasonable degree of
acceptance okay thank you
okay for the for the questions okay
Alan you don't want to comment on the
speed oh no I'm just going to mention
one thing you did mention with the um I
don't really want to get picky or
anything but you mentioned the
with the um consultation that was
undertaken
to be fair the consultation did yeah 60
or also wanted no change
so you didn't really go with
consultation plus Karen's Rose another
one another little individual road that
I've had we've got a feedback on as to
why a 60 going from 100 to 60.
where some retire Riders going from 100
to 80. and has a lot more houses and the
Karen's road is a Cheerio route for
anybody that works in Northern Chicago
from odotara no explaining why I know
you'll say there's Excellence but the
last section that I know of
don't know exactly what I was ahead on
and of course that could happen anywhere
if you competitive or sun cell phones or
anything so part of Karen road is there
is the crash history on the road which
has raised me high and that's part of
what leaned to us to suggest that 60
kilometers an hour
um typically the crashes that we're
seeing are on the bins which in the in
the lead up speed into it so that's what
made us propose that speed of 60ks
okay pania uh
just in regards to the road
speed limits and that oh I know we've
always had a problem with the Green
Point as well as Maui and we still
actually consumes being raised that
there still seem to be very high because
in the Green Point piece as you
come off Highway One
just see the entry part there that's
that's put there
um certainly the speeds we think we've
got a are in the right direction and I
would think in time as people become
more familiar with those speeds we'll
have an opportunity to either adjust
we've had people ring them up ring us up
and say they're too fast exactly that we
want them slower but I guess I would
like hope that some of that would be
more of an educational and bidding down
time and then we can go back and redress
any that we think we've need a little
tweak on the end of it yeah I think it's
because it's kind
of don't help situation
okay thanks but also I just want to come
back to the drive my life I see that um
the data that you've sort of provided is
like 2020 is there anything sort of more
current or is there intentions for ICC
to be more involved in this program
I think that the 2020 data is is the
last full year obviously with covert
we've had a little bit of disruptions
through there
our Command
commits through our road safety programs
through our subsidized work stream with
wakakatai so I guess it's a three-year
cycle but it's certainly one of the um
Road Safety promotional areas that we
continue to think is good value for
money along with other items that uh
like right track which I'll report next
activity on
um so can I just have a quick week um
quick question this in terms of the Maui
Road uh speed there I know that there's
a local group there that has been in
contact with you quite concerned about
the increase in the rotary effect
outside of the roads the speed limit and
that was due to the fact that they have
high use in certain times of the year
and there's lots of young children on
that Gravel Road and they're quite a few
some that their children will get hurt
so although the speed limit's been put
there at what time of consultation do
you go back and revisit that the
community there feels that after the
education that they are happy with that
speed
a Maui Road was previously 100
kilometers an hour and during the I
guess lead into this change we went
through and put signs up
in a post of the current speed and then
we removed this we replaced them with
the new speed so the speed of the Maui
road is now 60 kilometers an hour which
um could be it could be reduced further
should the community wish for going
forward but I would also remind I guess
the wider community that it is driving a
you know drive to the conditions drive
at a safe speed so I guess the speed
limit isn't the speed to have to it's
the it's the maximum speed you're
allowed to so I would think in the next
um somewhere in the next 12 to 24 months
would be a good period of time to
address some of those because we'll get
we'll get some stability over where the
changes are and we'll be able to
highlight those areas which uh too fast
or I guess the question will be as if
some of them actually need change we'll
have to decide on what the mechanism for
that is
thank you
Ellen uh that will also include too slow
as well that's too fast when you go will
you be revisiting some Road zip reps
I've increased like perhaps a bit to the
beach wall we would look at all the we
would look at all the speeds but but
generally we one of the things we do
know is that the faster you go the
bigger the crash so I guess that'll be
pretty much on our minds that that's why
we should all just do 10 kilometers an
hour
and I guess that's you know we want to
come out we we can then we continue to
have that that wider debate about what
the right speed it's what the the
terminology they use is a safe and
appropriate speed and I think if we
actually put it put in that context that
actually it
um summarizes it rather than a speed
limit what is the safe and appropriate
speed you should be traveling in if
everybody did that there would be right
councilor Clark was the final thing
sorry Mia Mia
this is a final question on what Russ
would just said as a response
um I'm not racist about six months ago
people who know that the road between
Nelson and Blenheim High Risk area
number of fatal accidents every year
they drop the speed limit from 100 down
to 80 and for one stretch they've got
double yellow lines for about 15
kilometers they've not had a serious
accident in the last two years
and all
right so when you drop it down yeah when
it's high you see the accidents when it
drops it down you don't notice that
there's actually an improvement it's not
something you do so yeah there
sorry as of last Thursday I think there
was 312 deaths on our roads across the
country and certainly in the last few
days that number
hasn't been static no no we've noticed
that right we've got four
recommendations
that we received the report uh that the
committee notes the implementation of
the speed limit changes on 17 October
2022 notes the broad cross section of
the business receiving information
requests as part of the proposed three
Waters transition and
uh notes the range of Works continuing
on Steed Street particularly with
environment Southland that will continue
over the next 12 months and the
resealing of the road
um can I have someone move those please
thanks Ria seconded Evelyn to put the
motion all those in favor against that
is carried that takes us on to the first
major late item
um
do we need
Patricia welcome
afternoon councilors this is the first
of two Road naming for this time and I
think by next month we might have
another one
um come through
these ones have been sitting waiting for
the new Council
um they are in accordance with their
policies so for the new councilors we
had we towards the end of the last
trainium we put in place a road naming
policy which
requires developers to provide us with
three names
not changes of Way Drive or Lane but
three names to go in the front
and set some criteria about how those
names should be determined
so we've been working with both these
Developers for the both papers to come
up so what would be appropriate names
for those areas
um and in front of you you for this
first one which is 182 and 186 Grant
Road there is three suggestions for each
of the two ways that are proposed as
part of the subdivision
right
um pania just one question
have they been sort of considered in
in relation to the district's culture
Heritage and geographical location so
for these ones a little work was done
about some names I do believe that the
um there was some requests put to
um to the two
um
about what what could be but the timing
just meant I don't think can't recall
whether we got a response back
but these were being based these two
these have been based on
historic Parts in what was happening in
that part of otatara back in the 1800s
okay any further questions regarding
this it's I mean it's good that they've
also listed their preferred uh they've
got their two preferred options as an
Amos
and flaxmill
there
both recommendations or that we receive
the report and
um
the proposed names based on what the uh
developers want okay so that is
um
with 2.1 will be Amos 2.2 flexible
flexible yep I'll second that okay
thanks Barry
um without any further comments or
questions uh put that motion all those
in favor
yes that is carried thanks that takes us
to the next one which is 299 adore
America roads
Patricia anything
um obviously their choice there is na
it's
um offices can look at the policy and
felt that called away may be a more
appropriate name however if that if the
committee felt that now was better
colder should be put on a list of
approved names and may have some links
to some future developments in within
the city
foreign
thanks chair um look I'm happy to move
the recommendation that the reports
received and that the right of way be
named called away I think now way
given the Southland accent creates
issues and that people might must hear
it as no way we do have a tendency of
adding art of things and and Nas become
Nars
doesn't know but I'd I did have a
question I know that
um
Council
I don't know if it's a policy I forget
just where it sits that we would
encourage the use of Maori names
um we've just approved three that are
not
um I think the nice names have been
chosen but I just wondered how that
interfaces with that other policy with
respecting Maori names
are you able to answer that Patricia we
were caving for it with
magnificently so that they are
appropriate names because developers
could put forward tereo names which may
not be considered appropriate for the
area so with it's a over time we need to
build up that database of of good names
or appropriate names
okay Alex then Evelyn um I believe that
it recorded at
um and it was an action point was that
our Council officers would take that
away and come back to us with a list of
appropriate names that we had you know I
would expect that to have already been
done by now we have opened it up to on
um a consultation platform but we've had
very little uptake of people providing
names
so we're still working with a local
public a local manafina would have come
up with some some names that can be used
in different areas
Evelyn so the challenge Mr chair aimed
with Audrey respect to everybody is that
I think rather than a generic poll of
names that people could use we would
really appreciate people looking at the
site and looking at something that is
relative to the site so I'm looking at
autoramaica
which if I hit it right would be
orticarama but anyway we won't go there
um you could use llama which is part of
that you could use Ika
or
any other combination thereof which had
some pertinence to the name of the
existing road that wasn't an option that
people looked at and that's fine
um but I don't think in terms of having
a generic pull most of the most commonly
chosen names have already been used so
what you're really looking now as you're
looking at something that might be
specific to a location specific to a use
that that place had for instance if you
look at the one that we've just done out
at utatura instead of flexible it could
be it could have been Haruka you know
because obviously harakiki is what you
make Flex out of
um
there was
um I don't have a problem with what has
been chosen I just think that us
providing a pool of names that don't
necessarily have any relevance to a
specific site
is not my preferred option
um and the most obvious names have
actually already been used
also in response to that totally agree
with Evelyn in regards to site Pacific
time
um naming but one of the things that did
come from
occur was really looking at our natives
in neutralizing those that kupu as well
as our our bird life our you know our
environment using those types of
um names it's something that meant
something to us a bit of this area or
this question
Nobby
yeah um
I I don't agree with the pawn the names
either I think that's too generic um but
maybe we need to think when we're
talking with the developer because
that's the first point of call that we
should be encouraging to think about
whether they're open to a suggestion
like that whether we want to force it or
not it's another issue because that
creates some issues as well because I
think historically we've allowed the
developers to
going to give us the pool of ideas it's
not always what they get but it that's
the first point of call it might be
helpful for going forward for future
options like this for our staff to touch
base with either or both of the
um minor funeral reps to suggest a name
that might as everyone said that might
be pertinent to the area that the
developer then thinks well actually
that's not a bad idea
so I don't think there's a bit of
whitening gun like just having a generic
pull
okay
speak again the point is that we need to
process
um I mean if I hear the discussion
clicker there is no process by which uh
Terio name could be considered
um so rather than have you know as
Evelyn has said rather than just a list
of genetic names you know Kia cack of
all that stuff
um that you would have a process by
which
um it might be that they are consulted
and that the developer is told of a
option
environment there is a process so we do
go through that
um oh we do that
so we have been reaching out to ask for
feedback
we have commented on other names in the
past and I've been asked to give advice
for example um
the subdivision that is going to use a
name from one of the anzacs I think it
was
um and I just sort of see well we would
not give authorization for a 2.0 of ours
to be used however if that particular
whanau wanted to use their person's name
that's up to them we would not give a
two point a name to a place so that's a
policy sort of matter that we gave some
advice on but yeah
okay
okay right we've got two recommendations
first one is we received the report
the second one is
um the committee has I take it decided
on call the way
can I have someone move those don't
Darren and seconded rear I'm gonna put
the motion all those in favor
the instant is carried that takes us
to the final item in public which is the
road closures for the South City Street
party
who's there
party person
I'm the default party person yeah
apologies for it slightness but uh we
received the request this morning from
um
the South City team to have a road
closure and to avoid us having to
decline it we've brought it today so we
appreciate the opportunity to present it
in terms of we haven't yet had the
approval from the police in wahukutahi
but they are pretty supportive and we
know that the process that we've
executed in the past to shut Alice Road
has worked relatively or very
successfully for that relatively short
period in the evening with the traffic
diverted so we believe that we will be
able to
a be able to have a safe traffic
management system which will cause
minimum disruption which I guess this
part of the legislation is the piece
that it's looking to to achieve
okay so I think these uh these
particular type of events and really
encourage Community involvement so yeah
it's great and there's no problem we'll
let the time restraints are very obvious
so it's good that you got it in here uh
question is going to start with Barry
did you have your hand up all right I'm
gonna go Trish then knobby so were they
told that it was
could they do it earlier next year
thanks for the question the answer to
both those is yes and our expectation is
that they would um do it they've just
got their timing a little bit out of out
of whack in this case
knobby so if we are to improve today
which is recommendation three I guess
it'll need to be subject to the police
I've been consulted as well remember the
same
so if you want to I guess if we want to
go ahead and approve it today it would
have to be subject to
staff getting some approval from the
police as well we just can't
say the Act requires that
I think if we note that Aaron do you
want to know
um both from wakakatahi and police
are they not affected
are we do really require their approval
due to the legislation actually asking
for the ministry of transports approval
and the minister of Transport have now
translated in this instance to work
that's right so they have many heads
Russell does the word regulatory
approvals cover all of those different
required parties that we have to consult
with that would be fine because
um the legislation actually specifies
the police end
excellent we have three recommendations
I have moved Evelyn seconded Grant or
put those motion for those three
recommendations all those in favor
aye against Kerry thanks Russell for
that
right but that takes us into public
excluded but um Logan and Louisa this is
only going to take a very very short
time so we can come and grab you if you
want to wait in the corridor out there
okay
streaming
um
once I find the items
oh [ __ ]